When you have a picture, you can think of it as a giant two-dimensional array
of colors. It's a little tedious to work with the colors because they have red,
blue, and green components. Here, we'll just use grayscale. Each element in the
two-dimensional array will represent a gray level. As an integer between zero
and 255. Now, here's the problem that we want to solve, we have a photo, which
is represented as a two-dimensional array, of lots of grey level. And now we
want to make it a little blockier. When I have groups of four neighbors like
this, I want to compute the average color or rather the average gray level of
these four pixels and color them all in that color. And this is, I'm making
every pixel a bit fatter. Let me blow this up a little. So here are the pixel,
and I want to know, what are it's three neighbors to the right, to the bottom,
and diagonally. So let's assume the one that I'm starting with is pixels ij,
that means my row is i, and my column is j. Let's look at the one to the right.
The row number is the same, and the column number has increased by one. So here
it is in Java. Same row, column increased by one. What about the one to the
south? In this case, the column index j is the same. And the row index has
increased by one. So here's the java code for that. Finally, the diagonal one
has both the row and column index increase by one. And I'll leave it to you in
the next lab exercise to figure that out. So go ahead and. Program this
exercise. You need to traverse the first pixel here then you jump by two each
time and also the columns you go down by two columns each time. In each step
you average these four pixels, compute the average value and stick it back into
all four pixels. Don't worry the friendly
[INAUDIBLE]
have given you some code to start with.